i've seen you
do a show
after the show do an after party
this is in tampa then go to the studio
no no no you went to club sky in tampa
after wild splash
and
you walked through the entire crowd and
hugged every person in this in the crowd
you're by myself by yourself
no security you literally
i mean we're talking about a club of
full 1500 people and this is like
this is i think you might have had two
phones out at this time
um
and i never seen anybody i was grateful
embrace
the people that were there to support
them the way you did that day i was like
this is i've never seen them the people
that love me for real so i was i was
grateful
i was grateful for that moment
i was grateful
so
i had to
i had to touch the people because i was
grateful yeah
has that ever gone wrong
no
well
i had a situation where
and it's so crazy
it was
it was the worst i i want to say it was
the worst thing that had ever happened
to me in my life but it really was the
best thing because
i wouldn't be where i'm at right now
i got a level of freedom that
most people only wish they had
but i was kind of blackballed
what happened in polk county yeah i was
kind of black bald like i never made
contact with the girl i tried to
i didn't even know that it was a girl
i just seen hands instead of grabbing
because the light was so bright right
but at the same time me being who i am
i'ma defend myself right that's like
somebody to talk about
man bro how you would feel if if that
that could have been my little sister
might have did that to your mama i don't
have no pigs also that's your set you're
still yeah like i don't see your safe
space i can't see who it is i did that
to your mama right how to do that to
your grandfather i don't have no pigs
win loser maybe that's all it was going
to be
like i don't have no pics like
this is what i i tell people that
and
it's like nobody understand they still
throw that at me say every time every
nine days but i'm like
my footage wasn't even permissible in
court i never made contact
it was no damages for her
i played soccer my whole life your head
would have came off your body
my daughter was on stage with me i had
to move my daughter to the back of the
stage
right yeah i think like and at that time
at that time being young being ignorant
being out the streets
you know
it's like
i'm a natural protector so i ain't
thinking about who down now i'm
protecting my tribe i'm a chief
and i feel like the stage if you're the
guy who also goes in the crowd and
embraces your fans you should also
have the stage be your safe place this
is one but it's just it's just i just
was crazy that it happened i was living
there when it happened it was just crazy
when it happened because i never made
contact but the world just blew it up
like he just did and i'm like what
then i end up going to jail
the charge
is a four hundred dollar fan i went to
jail for six months
so crazy for six months like i was
supposed to have a tea party with my
daughter
and it's like a live tour
like
i missed like two of her birthdays
it was just crazy i did six months
and then
i was already fighting the charge in
chicago which i was innocent on that
charge also
and i ended up doing 33 months
which i was supposed to do 36 months but
the judge showed leniency he didn't
abuse discretion so i guess that was a
good thing
but
i was innocent
but
i could also say that was the best thing
that ever could have happened to me
because
i wouldn't be when i met right now if
that wouldn't happen
like that was the best thing that could
have happened what were the because
some people
go through that and they come out on the
other side of it worse for it and some
people go through it and they come out
on the other side of it with more growth
and to come out better
how did what were the things that you
kind of took away from that
is
obviously sitting down for 33 months is
a serious chunk it's
it's trying at times you know
but my eyes was open
to reality and reality is harsh and the
world is a very cruel place
it is
and every time i meet people that's
dealing with depression and suffering i
tell them man the world's a cruel place
trust me i know
but i had time to sit with myself
like the six months in florida i was
like man yeah i'm gonna do it this way
when i go back out there
but
i wasn't all the way ready
then when i went to chicago
i was like
i'm gonna do it this way after like
maybe a year
but as i got longer into the bed
i just was like
it had stripped me it broke me all the
way down
to
being more appreciative
being more appreciative
and that's when i that's when i really
sit with myself for the first time
any other time i went to jail you know i
was in the mix
right this time it was like
i had matured